ever thought about a steam deck i mean
you know that seems like i've got a
steel deck oh you do that's the perfect
on tour device then right here oh no no
oh
not oh that's a stream deck
that's claudio sanchez singer and
songwriter for co-heating cambria and
earlier this week i had the pleasure of
speaking with him all about his favorite
games and how they've influenced him
creatively as well as the band's new
album vaxxis2 window of the waking mind
it's finally here
10th studio album congratulations on
that as well oh thank you so now release
day does it feel any different 20 years
after the second stage turbine blade
this one's this one's kind of
interesting because the record has been
done about a year now the thing that
really took most of the time was uh
acquiring all the assets like
constructing the story getting the relic
made which is actually those like two
little circular objects on the top of
that modular synth so this release was
different because we've been sitting on
it for so long we're all really thrilled
about the record and excited to have it
come out for people to listen to even
though there's two decades separating
your first album and this new album
they're still connected in a way right
yeah absolutely they all fall under the
umbrella of the amary wars the story arc
that uh that companions the albums when
you think about video games story lines
the emery wars saga is perfect for fans
of what i'd probably go with halo i
think of when i was writing in keeping
secrets like i think halo had just come
out and that was like the thing i was
jumping back and forth you know between
i had uh upgraded from a cassette four
track to an eight-track digital recorder
i had it at a desk in the corner of the
room with the console on the other side
on the other side of the room and i
would bounce back and forth between
writing material for that record and
playing halo i mean i'm just i'm
very much into like big world building
science fiction and i think halo kind of
is is that you know so if i had to pick
something it would be that but that said
as far as i understand like going
through all of them i'm up to halo
infinite there isn't really a master
chief relationship right so i would
probably have to go
with like a double dragon because a lot
of the stories that coheed and cambria
are based after about these like two
people coming together in a relationship
and
an overcoming obstacle so maybe i'd
throw like a double dragon in there just
because you know there's a hero and a
love interest i guess that perfectly
like leads into what i was gonna ask
next because your personal life is such
an inspiration to the characters and the
worlds that you've created all these
years so i was wondering how gaming
influenced and helped your creative
process and it seems like halo
is pretty big up there this is funny but
when i think of like welcome home the
intro to welcome home is very much feels
like it's in the same the key of yeah
the key of tetris i'm so surprised that
no one has done a welcome home tetris
mashup because
listen to those things side by side
and you'll be like whoa part of me feels
like the tetris theme after playing it
so many times on gameboy was
somewhere in the back of my subconscious
when like constructing this the intro to
welcome home because returning to that
game on like the switch i was like wow
that kind of
sounds like welcome home
that would have been perfect yeah right
so other than tetris if you could have
your music in a game what would it be
and why would be elden ring why would it
be elden ring um yeah i'll just i just
threw it out there just just for fun you
can you can choose whatever you want
um why would it be elder ring because i
actually really enjoy elden ring that's
it that's the thing is i you know would
be fun to do something like that for
something i enjoy every once in a while
i have a game that i'll uh look forward
to out on the road and uh one tour it
was red dead redemption 2 and this last
one we were on was elden ring and i find
because you know i'm on tour you know
there's so much down time that i'm
allowed to get invested in the game and
eldon ring is one of them so once i got
home i rarely play it unless i'm on
twitch i don't really have a chance to
like i'm here doing you know my fatherly
duties ah so
that's a game i'll definitely be like
playing while i'm out there but i would
i would why would it be that because
simply because i i think that game is
awesome the aesthetic the characters the
villains one of the last ones i'd i'd
fooled around with was the
godric the grafted is that his name yeah
the fact that these characters are like
sort of sewn together and have like
multiple limbs and just feel really odd
and like misshapen i really enjoyed the
the look of the game for sure what's
your gaming setup like on tour which is
just like a console are you on a tour
bus with a really beefy pc
no uh
so it's very run and gun you know before
this tour we were actually going to
build a setup but i just have not had a
chance to get around it um so this this
tutorial will simply be like my ps5 in
like a pelican case i wish it was more
uh set up and i didn't have to you know
put everything together um every time i
had to do it but uh
but yeah that's about it ever thought
about a steam deck i mean you know that
seems like i've got a steel deck oh you
do that's the perfect contour device
then right here oh no no no
oh
not oh that's a stream deck
i was just saying the poor see i'm not
too familiar with that the steam steam
deck portable system
oh man all right let's let's head back
to the album one track that really
stands out to me is a disappearing act
um it feels so different from
what kohi has done in the past can you
talk a little bit about how that song
came to be
yeah it was almost uh a happy accident
it was a song that i was fooling around
with
put in a hard drive left
may have never seen the light of day had
i not brought it out to la and uh we
just put it together and i started to
like construct the lyrics sort of about
you know kind of being
you know in lockdown and like feeling
like trapped inside myself
and just waiting for you know a chance
to come out and when you did you know
realizing all the time
you lost the title track is also a big
standout it really feels like just
listening to it closing your eyes you're
watching a stage show and i can i i can
just imagine what that would even sound
like being played live right because at
this point in the story the character of
axis is coming out of his um out of his
state like like to his parents it looks
like he's in this catatonic state but in
actuality he's living like
multiple different versions of life like
almost like uh like a multiverse sort of
situation like he sees every
outcome at once to the point of like
static speaking of multiverses
you know fortnite has dealt with that a
bunch of times the fortnite also has
characters like travis scott and ariana
grande and now smite has slipknot in it
what game if if you guys want to be in a
game what game could you see kohi being
like an unlockable skin in
oh okay so for me it would either be a
fortnight or call of duty okay nice i
was thinking
yeah just because those are the games i
play if i play competitively although
i'm not very competitive i suck but um
you know uh
but i i do those are the games i usually
stream and play um
and i can see
certainly with with call of duty i can
definitely see the skins of like sister
spider or or uh creature you know with
their masks and uh their artillery like
they they seem perfect and i and i've
asked management if like what is the
outlet to try to get that to happen
because i can definitely see those
characters running around um
you know
in that game as far as like as uh
fortnite goes i mean any anything i mean
i would you could pick a character from
you could pick a personality from the
band or or any of the characters from
any of the mythology it's so crazy that
like
you know they're here and and people
enjoy them and i you know enjoy them and
it's awesome so awesome thanks for
watching for more on claudio make sure
you watch our video where he reacts to
doom metal health singer and more kohi's
latest album is available now so make
sure you leave a comment letting me know
your thoughts on the new tunes and give
this video a thumbs up for more content
like it
[Music]